حول الفاجعه التي حلت بمدينه درنه التي
كانت جنه يوما ما ما زال وسيبقى يثقل كاهل
اهلها الى وقت ليس بقريب
فحصيله القتل النهائيه بالالاف والمفقودين
بعشرات الالاف اما المتضررين فلا يمكن
احصائهم
في خضم هذا الدمار وتحت ركامل انقاض دفنت
اعوام من الاهمال الاداري وعدم المسؤوليه
المجتمعيه والتي تمثلت بتجاهل العديد من
الدراسات التي كانت تحذر مما ستؤول اليه
الاوضاع بحال حدوث عاصفه اخرها كانت دراسه
نشرت منذ عام توقعت بحدوث ما حصل لدرنه
اجر الدكتور ونيس بن طاهر احدى هذه
الدراسات فلجا في بحثه الى صور الاقمار
الصناعيه وطرق الاستشعار عن بعد فما الذي
تمحورت حوله هذه الدراسه عن سدود درنه كان
الدراسه في
2006 لحصول على الماجستير قمت بتقييم كامل
لجريان السطحي بحوض وادي درنه بعد ما
انهيت في 2020 انغمست مره اخرى في في
تقييم ومراجعه مدرسته في الماجستير فقمت
بتحديث الدراسه بتقنيات وسائل حديثه من
ضمنها صور صناعيه حديثه طرق الحديثه في
الاستشعار عن بعد وبعض المعادلات اللي انا
توقعت انها تعطي نتائج اكثر دقه
وركزت على الفيضانات التي حدثت في حوض
وادي دارنا في السابق من ضمن فيضان 1986
والفيضات
1959 لانه في دراسه السابقه
توقعت انك يرجع الفيضان بتاع سنه
1959 بعد 60 سنه نحن عندنا لكل فيضان فتره
حوده في المستقبل فانا ركزت على هذين
الفيضانيين بالاخص على فيضان التسعه
وخمسين وجدت ان لو حدث هذا الفيضان بكميه
الامطار بالعوامل التعريه اللي صارت للحوض
بالتعدي على الغطاء النباتي بعض المشاكل
اللي هي البناء العشوائي في مجاري الاوديه
فلما وصلت الى
40% من مجموع جريان السنوي بالكامل ممكن
تحدث عندي في يوم واحد وهذا مؤشر خطير جدا
ممكن يؤدي الى انهيار السدود وتصير عندي
كارثه في مدينه درنه وفي حوض للاسف الشديد
هذا هو اللي حدث البقاء في الانهار والعيش
في مناطق ساحليه قد تكون لها عواقب على
السكان فما هي ابرزها وما الذي يجب على
الناس الحذر منه
[موسيقى]
ما عنديش انا زلزال يعني عاصفه مطريه
شديده فللاسف الشديد كان تركيز اللجنه
الطوارئ على المناطق الساحليه واخراج
الناس من المناطق الساحليه لو كان تم
اجلاء منطقه الدلتا وهي المنطقه التي
تترسب فيها كميات
الضمي والطين القادم من الفيضانات ممكن
نتجنبنا هذه الكارثه بالاضافه الى وضع
كاميرات مراقبه على جسم السدين وحتى تكون
على الهواء مباشره معروضه في القنوات بحيث
ان تبعنا منسوب المياه بمجرد ما تقترب
كميه المياه من الاسبنويل يبدا الاخلاء
فوري يعني تكون لجنه طوارئ ولجنه ازمه
والاعلام يشتغل على جميع المستويات بحيث
اننا نخت لمنطقه الدلتا هي العشره كيلو
متر مربع اللي صارت فيها المشكله في في
مدينه درب من جانبها شددت الدكتوره ساره
فؤاد على ضروره نشر الوعي حول مخاطر العيش
بجانب القنوات المائيه هنا الدور التوعوي
اساسه انه الناس تكون جزء من التطوير
المشاريع التطهير اللي بتحصل في المدن
فاول اول حاجه خالص لازم نعمل توعيه للناس
ولازم الناس تكون جزء من المشاريع
التطويريه اللي بتحصل بنبني عليها فكره
التغيرات المناخيه يعني احنا لازم
المشاريع اصلا الدوله بتعملها
متجهه اساسا لفكره انه هنا هيحصل مشكله
يعني هنا هتحصل في مخاطر فاحنا لازم نعمل
المشروع دي على اساس ان احنا نواجه
المخاطر دي هي المشكله اللي موجوده تقريبا
في معظم الدول العربيه انه في النهايه في
فصل كامل بين
المؤسسات التعليميه او بين الجامعات
والمؤسسات البحثيه والناس اللي تقدر تاخذ
القرار وفي النهايه
انت ما تقدرش تكون واصيه على على من يتخذ
القرار في النهايه